a city of tents
this is life for around 250
000 syrians forced from their homes by
the civil war
and now after 10 years of continued
conflict
snow and rain is their latest enemy
the very cold weather the massive volume
snow and the bad condition of the camp
have led to the tense damages everywhere
we ask allah and we urge those who are
willing to help do their best for us
we don't have firewood and there is no
heating we burn some shoes and clothes
just to offer some heat to the children
traveling to the area was already
difficult
the snow has made it near impossible aid
agencies are struggling to get access
tents have collapsed under the weight of
the snow
the few that do have shovels do what
they can
the rest are left to move snow with
their hands in freezing temperatures
the whole camp does not have bread we
call upon the humanitarian organization
and all the authorities concerned to
urgently help the camp in its residence
the un says more needs to be done but
for the people here they need help now
the whole camp is in real danger and we
don't know what to do we have spent the
last seven to eight years in tents and
displaced camps they can't find us a
flat
the camps are inadequate at the best of
times
the snow is only adding to the misery
these people face assad big al jazeera